Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's the last week of Pizzamas
That means there's only a few more days to get
your Pizzamas stuff at Pizzamas.com
including all of our amazing t-shirts and this
super snuggly blanket and this color changing mug!
By the way, we now have some discount bundles
including the cozy bundle
which includes this blanket and
the mug for $30 off
Okay Hank so full disclosure
I'm anxious so
let's go outside because it does actually help me to like
touch grass and be amid trees
It's so weird to me how much
life there is on earth like
This is life
You made a TikTok once where you pointed
out that humans have
relatively brief lifespans and
our species hasn't been around for that long
But if we think
of ourselves as part of one
continuous biological
phenomenon called life
then things start to look quite
different because life on
Earth has existed continuously
for about 3.7 billion years
Which is around 23% of the
history of the entire universe
So like, we are young, and most species we
currently share the planet
with are fairly young
Like, even the tuatara, which
existed before the emergence
of large dinosaurs, is only
around 250 million years old,
which is less than 10% of the
history of life on Earth
So yeah, we're new, most other
things that we see are new,
But life is very old
And I do find that a little comforting.
But when you're walking
through an urban-ish forest,
you don't only see life, of course
You also see steel husks and concrete structures
that were once used to house barrels
of whiskey during Prohibition
This forest used to be private property
owned by Albert Lieber
who made and lost a fortune selling booze
and who was also the grandfather
of the novelist Kurt Vonnegut
And we're in a city, so the human-shaped
world is everywhere
Even in the forest, from the invasive
ivy to the extraordinarily polluted White River
There's no full separation between
these worlds, not really
We try to claim that this is artificial
and this is natural
but concrete and steel are made out of earth,
just like everything else is
Alright, I'm starting to
breathe a little easier
I'm part of a continuous process
of life that stretches back
A quarter of the way to the
beginning of time
and I'm in a world
I'm walking
This is a good place to be, all things considered
It's a good earth
My friend Henry in Sierra Leone
likes to say that when he sees
beauty or goodness in the world
that he is encouraged
So yeah, I'm feeling encouraged
One nice thing about
Indianapolis in October
the leaves are starting to fall
If you pitched this idea to someone
who'd never been to Earth
I think they would find it
phenomenally beautiful
So each cycle,
we would explain to these non-Earth folk,
Each cycle, it gets colder in parts
of our world as we tilt away from our star
and our most numerous
and visually prominent  life forms,
which are called trees,
simultaneously change
The fluttering soft green appendages at the end
of these trees are called leaves and
these leaves erupt into bright
colors that we associate with our star
Reds, oranges,
yellows and then huge swaths
of leaves fall to the ground
until the ground is covered with them
The trees spend the cold months
without their leaves
and then, as our earth begins to
tilt back toward its star
the trees regrow their leaves
This goes on growing and falling,
growing and falling
for dozens or even hundreds of cycles
It goes on for so long that leaves
dropped by young trees may in time
become soil that helps support
that same tree as it gets older
In a very real way, our trees are nourished
by what they let go of
by what they leave behind
What an encouragement I find that to be
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.